okay so because response to Thor god of
thunder has been so huge we are going to
run through this to its fruition which
is actually like maybe two more videos
and that's really it it's pretty short
but one of the things that you guys are
going to notice is that everything with
by Jane Foster Thor all comes out of
this this is why I've been saying it's
just one great big cohesive story now
again one thing to keep in mind is that
there is a story called Loki agent of
Asgard and Loki agent of Asgard actually
ties in to I think it's the last days of
Midgard basically to the idea that the
entire earth has been destroyed and the
far distant future not really like
destroyed in terms of a planet being
blown up but destroyed in the sense that
Loki basically killed everybody on earth
but in order to understand lucky agent
of Asgard we have to understand why
Loki's a teenager and in order
understand why he's a teenager we have
to understand why he's a boy why he is
safe when he's a chick and all that
really comes out of thor ragnarok so
we're going to cover all that stuff once
we get around to November and we end up
getting back into the thor ragnarok and
the post Ragnarok story so the
rebuilding of Asgard and you know fear
itself and all I kind of get stuff all
that's going to get covered because it's
a pretty cool thing and the interesting
about that is that Jason Aaron's run
actually all comes out of that stuff
which is really kind of cool but the
fact remains here that what we do is we
basically pick up with the return of
Malekith via curse now
Malekith prior to jason Aaron's run was
really just kind of like a four villain
who would just pop up and just cause
problems he was not really a character
to be taken seriously any certain wasn't
you know he wasn't really written as
well as he is here but initially this
brings us to nip l'homme I think it's
how you pronounce it or Niffleheim but
it brings us to basically this realm of
Hell now here's the funny thing about
this in Marvel Comics with the Asgardian
mythos tell is not hell as you think of
it which is to say like fire and
brimstone and like an eternity of
damnation and suffering and so on and so
forth not at all that's really more like
Mephisto as well like you know but this
shows version of hell with regards to
Asgard this is really more of like we're
just average folks go so people who are
part of like the nine realms and are
familiar with the Asgardian mythos or
people in like Jotunheim or something
like that ah they will end up basically
die and then going to hell it's not
really a place where you suffer it's
just a place where people who didn't
know people who died who weren't like
warriors so like when Thor dies he'll go
to Valhalla that's where he'll go he'll
go to a paradise for warriors
who died in combat who died bravely for
anybody else they'll just kind of go to
hell more or less it's kind of a weird
thing to say like good people go to hell
I guess it's kind of a weird scenario
but Malekith had basically been confined
to hell and the reason why is because
you know during the whole incredible
Hercules storyline and so on and so
forth he just kind of been isolated
there but he was in a section that
basically had a place called the pit of
Sorrows and the pit of Sorrows is one of
those realms as basically confined for
people who are considered to be
incorrigible which is to say bad guys
who just won't change and the pit of
sorrow is actually designed to be a
place where no one can escape like once
you're confined there you will
effectively be there for all eternity
where at least until you know Ragnarok
when all the nine realms come crashing
down and Asgard is destroyed but
Malekith was previously king of the Dark
Elves and when Malekith was reigning
over the Dark Elves they were basically
evil but when Malekith was imprisoned
and when he was basically removed from
the Dark Elves then things began to sort
of fracture some of the Dark Elves
became refugees and took off to Asgard
and basically hung out there for a while
other members of the Dark Elves either
went to earth and change what they look
like some also went to the other nine
realms or any of the other realms and
the whole Asgardian Pantheon and just
lived there but for the most part they
stopped being like evil guys and they
just kind of lived out their lives
normally however there were some who
were still loyal to Malekith and that's
what's happening here effectively those
individuals who were loyal to him are
breaking him out of the pit of Sorrows
now again because of the fact that this
is designed to house gods the kind of
critters that you end up seeing around
here are pretty deadly I mean like a lot
of the snakes and so on and so forth you
know I don't they'll kill you you know
with a single bite and so again you know
these house snakes and these monsters
and so on they're pretty deadly and
pretty dangerous but once Malekith is
broken out what happens there's only one
guy left this guy basically by the name
of scum tongue and the idea of malakut
is to basically restore the Dark Elves
to their rightful place on the cool
thing about this is that this is
actually going to end
basically with Malick it's forming his
own leaf so those are guys who are
reading Jane Foster Thor that's where
that comes from when the guys from rocks
on oil are rolled in when Loki becomes a
part of that group this is the roots
this is the origin of how it all comes
into fruition so again it's all just one
great big huge epic and it's actually
really really cool what we end up doing
here is we of course pick up with Thor
and you know various members of these
different groups and so on and the world
is kind of drinking alcohol like you do
when your sword and then
one of the Dark Elves begins freaking
out talking about how startled hime is
burning and so of course with the
Warriors 3 & 4 responding they arrive on
far behind only to find out to this land
of the Dark Elves it's basically being
razed and only one person has managed to
survive and she actually is I'm having
her arm cut off by Malekith himself now
Assyria is actually kind of a cool
character and believe it or not she will
actually show up again in fact she did
just show up and I want to say it was
when Odin Sun and Jane Foster Thor
fought the Phoenix force which is an
amazing story is so good like we need to
cover that ah God the Asgard see our war
is so cool it's one of the coolest
stories to come out of come out of
Marvel Comics but basically this is just
the idea that you know Malekith of
course makes his escape
Thor and his guys are able to cauterize
the wound of Waziri ax cauterize her arm
as well as Valek if basically beginning
his campaign to begin killing Dark Elves
or you know just kind of eliminating
them all over the place now the cool
thing about this is that malakut has his
own motivations and he has his own and
his own intentions but what we end up
doing here in the interim is we actually
transition over to a place called Asgard
eeeh now as Gardea for those of you guys
who aren't really familiar with the Thor
landscape this is the second iteration
of Asgard winding back the clock for a
second um following the events of
Ragnarok when Thor was quote-unquote
dead once he came back he basically
reformed Asgard on earth in Broxton
Oklahoma and of course after a fight
between himself and Tony Stark where he
beat the hell out of Iron Man it was
amazing he ended up levitating Asgard
above the ground by like a few feet or
something along those lines but during
the events of siege Asgard was destroyed
and so what ended up happening is Tony
Stark basically recreated Asgard and had
it stationed in Broxton Oklahoma and
then added a few you know improvements
to it giving it like you know additions
that would allow it to float and so on
and so forth but this new version of
Asgard was called Asgardian now for
those of you guys who are reading for
right now and you're like but there's
also an ask in Asgard yes that the
original Asgard was reformed by Odin so
you have the original Asgard in the
realm of Asgard and then you have as
Gardea on earth so they're just two
different places the thing here is that
fours mother Freya is basically the one
who is ruling as Gardea and Odin is
sitting on the throne at Asgard and
that's really he's just kind of hanging
out there by himself he's just sort of
in isolation but in any event the reason
why this is important is because of the
fact
with Malekith having escaped a hell and
basically going on a crusade to kill all
the Dark Elves Freya basically brings
together this sort of Lord of the Rings
esque fellowship in the form of like the
the light elves and the dwarves and
trolls and you know giants of different
things like that and they are all
effectively going to serve the purpose
alongside for Andros area who's used to
her sorcery can regrow her arm to
basically track down now I can't try to
stop him where they can and ultimately
kill him the problem with this is that
every single step of the way everywhere
they go
Malekith is always one step ahead and
it's just killing you know dark elf
after dark elf every single place he
finds it now this is where the
motivation of a Malekith begins to come
into play and the reason why is because
during their first major outing during
their first major assault on malakut and
his forces ultimately they're
unsuccessful just because of the fact
that you know trying to fight dark elves
and the shadows where they can
manipulate you know and kind of stay
hidden from the normal human eye and so
on and so forth
ultimately leads to them all being
defeated but malakut is not killing the
dark elves for no reason the reason why
he's killing the dark elves is because
of the fact that in his mind he's going
to push them to the absolute limit and
the reason for this is actually given to
us later on in the story what kind of
get to that here in a second but again
you know trying to track down these
various members of Mallika's forces and
so on you know ultimately leaves to Thor
and his group actually taking a break
and a place called the gingerbreads
habit which is I believe is in the realm
realm of the light elves although I'm
not going to swear to it but the fact
remains here the reason why this whole
trip is being done the reason why this
whole you know drinking scenario is
being played out is because as Guardians
and the various warriors from the
different realms really pride themselves
on how much alcohol they can consume and
how well they can fight it's like the
one thing they have in common it's just
kind of this barbarian mentality but
what Thor is ultimately shooting for is
that where these members of the League
of realms are basically in fighting
they're fighting against one another two
bickering because they have so many
differences because lydell's don't like
dwarves and dwarves don't like trolls
and nobody likes Giants because of the
fact that they're arguing so much Thor
is hoping that even if only for this
moment they can find some sort of common
ground and in finding common ground they
can use this as a stepping stone to put
their differences aside so again it's
very Lord of the Rings s in the sense
that you had like Gimli
you know son of Gloin I think it was and
Legolas becoming friends as time
progressed despite the fact that they
despise one another when they first met
really is just like you know kind of a
lot of character development but it's
also giving us a tour of these different
things as they go on but the fact
remains here that in terms of again you
know this whole idea of bringing the
group together this whole idea of Malick
is real intention here what we end up
doing is we actually end up seeing him
invoking the frost giants now this is a
pretty big deal and the reason why is
because in the realm of Jotunheim it's
basically just kind of like the land of
giants so you have mountain giants and
you have all different kinds of giants
but the frost giants are the ones that
everybody fears and the reason is
because most Giants aren't wildly
intelligent they're really not wildly
capable and the frost giants aren't
super intelligent but they are born and
bred for battle all they want to do is
destroy things and so when they set
their sights on you they will easily
kill you not only that their ability to
manipulate the casket of ancient winters
to basically bestowed its infinite cold
on whatever it is that they go basically
makes them wildly deadly to anyone they
come across god or otherwise now they
can be defeated I mean if Odin for
example were to like go against all the
frost giants he could probably take them
out I mean it wouldn't be wildly
impossible but it would still create a
very dangerous situation and so with
really this this mountain giant of Thor
having been defeated and with the frost
giants allied with Malekith what this
does is it basically pushes the forces
of the League of realms to their
absolute limit in the sense that they
are not necessarily able to take things
down and take Malekith down as easily as
they believed they were going to be able
to do just because of the fact that now
Alan kids can send his frost giants into
the conflict and basically just start
crushing dark elves faster than he was
before
not to mention entire realms will be in
danger because if the frost giants show
up with a casket of ancient winters and
open it up that entire realm will just
freeze over will just cause absolute
panic and kill virtually everyone not
only that because of the fact that
Malekith is constantly a step ahead of
everything that's going on with regards
to Thor and his forces the only logical
conclusion Thor can come to is that
somebody somewhere is spun somebody is
releasing the information to Malekith
constantly keeping him aware of what it
is that they're doing now the crazy
thing about this is his initial reaction
is that it's actually dude the troll and
this kind of makes sense and the reason
why is because of the fact the trolls
are very isolationist and trolls are
really more like cowards than anything
else there are some who are brave but
trolls will really only fight if there's
a benefit for them or if they see a
reason to
the problem with this is that in the
various conflict that they had food the
troll had never really stepped in I mean
he had fought here and there but he just
kind of been there just kind of been
around and that was really it he really
hadn't done a whole lot and so in the
mind of Thor food control is probably
the most logical person to be the trader
especially considering the fact that
when they at first encountered malakut
and malakut had escaped this had
happened because of the fact that when
Thor intended to kill Malekith who the
troll had stepped in and stayed his hand
and so in the eyes of thorn
it's basically who the troll keeping
Malekith alive and so in light of all
this Thor kills through the troll by
smashing his head with the hammer now
what this does is it basically kind of
breaks apart the League of Wells because
at this point they begin looking at Thor
and they see him as paranoid now of
course was serious sticks around just
because of the fact that her people were
massacred or at least her tribe of the
dark elves were massacred by Malecha so
at this point it's really more like a
blood vendetta than anything else but
for the other members of the league you
know for the for the you know the
dwarves and for you know the light elves
and so on Malekith is not coming after
their forces and so for them it's really
more than being here just to kind of be
here as a person having to have to be
here you know as opposed to it being
unnecessary and so ultimately they just
kind of bail out they effectively just
just sort of take off and so what is up
happening is Thor in what Syria
basically travel to Midgard they travel
to earth and what they end up doing is
they actually walk into this butcher
shop which turns out to basically be a
meeting place for these various heads of
the Dark Elves tribes now this is again
really designed to show us how deep the
roots go with regards to like the
Asgardian mythos and how earth plays a
role into it because remember when it
comes to like the nine realms and the
you know the tree of Idris so is one of
the one of these ideas of the nine
realms are basically all just kind of
connected to one another and they all
share a common fate that's the reason
why when Thor had basically destroyed
the tree of inter-cell it had broken off
all the nine realms that's the reason
why angela's realm of heaven was cut off
from the tree of idris ill and we never
knew about it before because they all
basically share this sort of common
theme and so those individuals who were
cut off from it and no one will know
they exist so it was kind of be this
free-floating realm out there that no
one knows anything about but the idea
here is that the Dark Elves at least the
leaders of the Dark Elves
aren't necessarily panicking so much as
they're trying to figure out what to do
but they've all basically been brought
together by for himself now the problem
with this is that the Dark Elves
basically engage in politics by virtue
of combat
hablas called the introductory static
and the introductory stabbing is where
they basically say okay here's what I
stand for and here's my stand for and
then they start attacking each other
based on you know how they're going to
open their argument it's really kind of
a weird thing but it's basically also
this idea that the Dark Elves really
kind of stem themselves and involve
themselves more so in combat than
anything else now of course because of
the fact that all these leaders are
brought into one singular location and
because of the fact that you know Thor
is basically playing a ruse here this
inevitably brings Malekith to their
location and this is when we ultimately
find out what's happening here that
we're Thord basically begins to like
attack other members of the Dark Elves
claiming that they're all that they're
all spies the spy actually turns out to
be for himself and the reason why is
because of the fact that Malick has
actually had one of his dark elf allies
bug Thor this again is kind of a weird
scenario but it also shows us how far
out there things can be when it comes to
Asgard and a whole you know Asgardian
mythos and so on that where you would
traditionally think of somebody being
bugged like you put a little device on
them so you can track their location or
listen to the conversations or converse
a combination of both amy has Guardian
mythos is actually putting a bug in them
now we kind of have to believe this bug
has some sort of telepathic connection
with Malekith or swimming along those
lines but nonetheless it basically
allowed Thor to be the to be the traitor
without anybody knowing it but the funny
thing about this is that Thor actually
knew what was going on the entire time
and the reason this happens is because
of the fact that the league of realms
Returns alongside dude the troll and
what we end up finding out here is that
where Malekith asked the question how in
the world is it here I literally saw you
kill him Thor basically kind of makes
this sort of allusion to the idea that
was Loki being his brother the Thor had
picked up some sort of you know some
combination of spells along the way now
Jason Aaron's playing it fast and loose
with this right like it's really just
more of a convenience thing but it also
kind of makes sense right I mean Thor
and Loki were always like opposite sides
of the same coin Thor was the lawyer say
he has the hammer yes millionnaire he
just flies in the combat just starts
smacking people around and that's really
it Loki is more cunning love use more
manipulative Loki delves with magic but
Loki knows how to fight and Thor knows
how to use magic now if Thor's knowledge
of sorcery is nowhere near what Loki
says I mean he's nowhere near that level
but it doesn't mean he doesn't know how
to use magic it doesn't mean that he's
not capable of picking up little tips
and tricks here and then
at the end of the day it still works out
in his favor and so because of this
where he initially intends it actually
tries to take out malakut for time he's
actually successful now a tip is
basically subdued by a combination of
the dark force I guess the Dark Elves as
well as Thor himself now where Thor goes
to kill him what ends up happening is
his hand is stayed by the Dark Elves and
the reason why is the intention of
Malekith going through all this malakut
wanted to unite his forces and so did
Thor Thor wanted to unite the forces of
the Dark Elves against Malekith Malekith
wanted to unite the forces of the Dark
Elves to his side and that's exactly
what they did the Dark Elves are combat
proficient I mean they literally exist
to like raise worlds and the cause
problems they are in some degrees an
evil group because of the fact that
malakut was so capable and taking them
all out and because the fact that
Malekith was at one time their king
ultimately the different heads of the
tribes come together the council makes a
decision and they effectively vote
Malekith as being their king and so what
this does is this sets the stage for
Malekith beginning his war against the
nine realms his intention to invade and
wipe out all life across the nine realms
making himself absolute ruler over
everything and so one of them happening
here is was Arya she actually takes the
place of malakut within Hell in the in
the pit of woe and again this actually
sets the stage and allows Jason Erin to
put her on the backburner and then bring
her back later on down the line which
again you know she's going to be a
relatively important character here but
for this moment for this right now it's
basically this idea that Malekith as
king of the Dark Elves begins the
process of basically bringing his forces
together mustering his various forces
together and creating his own League
this basically kind of the antithesis of
the league of realms but creating his
own league for the purpose of beginning
his campaign to attack all the different
realms and make himself absolute ruler
but with that being said guys we are
going to bring this video to an end if
you guys are new here make sure you guys
have a sub button to become part of
comics explain I guess part of the rob4
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like in the next video we
will pick up with old King for the last
days of Midgard and this idea that
everything that everybody loves is going
to happen when Thor fights Galactus over
that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all let it peace
[Music]